ravens meanwhile have seven players on
the covet 19 reserve list due to close
contact
with marlon humphrey they'll be
available
saturday morning i believe saturday
morning
if it was yesterday that that started
they can return after five days
look at the guys though who won't be
available to practice this week in
advance of a game at indianapolis
matthew judon who was ejected
from sunday's loss to the steelers
patrick queen one of the candidates for
defensive rookie of the year
among others who will be unavailable
this week as the
the ravens prepare and you know the
nfl's desire to get games in
it pay you let the virus into your
building
you have guys who are in close contact
you're the one that
faces the strategic disadvantage of not
being able to get your guys ready we saw
with the raiders a couple weeks ago
we're going to see it with the ravens
this week yeah we saw it with the
raiders offensive line and you know they
came back and
unfortunately for trent brown he wasn't
able to play anyway because of the iv
mishap but they hope to get these guys
back in the game but missing practice
time just hurts you know
mike sometimes it just feels like like
it's a team's year
like this feels like it's a steelers
year and
on the other hand it feels like it
sometimes it's not a team's year and you
look at the 49ers and the cowboys and
the broncos and
now the ravens and it just there's just
a feeling you get that maybe it's just
not their year
with the covet issues and injury issues
and everything else
that's gone on with ravens has been
lamar jackson not playing like he did
last year in his mvp year but it just
starting to feel
to me like maybe this just isn't the
ravens
year and that's unfortunate for me
because they were my pre-season favorite
to win the super bowl
well mom was a tampa bay buccaneer so
i'm feeling pretty good about that right
now but i also had the patriots making
it out of the afc and they're not dead
yet
the terminator is not dead yet but you
make a good point about covet 19. look
we ha
we saw in training camp uh the one
clip i saw from hard knocks this year
anthony lynn telling his
players on the chargers hey whoever
masters this is going to be in position
to win the super bowl and
i i suspect that that mike tomlin
understood what he needed to say how he
needed to communicate
and the level of fear and i don't mean
that in a bad way
look one one of the ways that a coach
holds his team together and gets his
players
to do what he wants them to do is have
them
scared of what will happen if they don't
do
what the coach says and this isn't
something the steelers are going to
advertise to the world
but we haven't seen or heard any stories
of steelers players
out and about doing things they
shouldn't do there haven't been any
videos of steeler
players out in restaurants or bars my
guess is between
the veteran leadership on that team and
the head coach
no one is going to bring that virus into
the facility because
everyone is going straight home and
keeping themselves clean and clear
as best they can from the virus now it's
still impossible to
completely insulate it from it but i
think this is one of the reasons why the
steelers are having a special season
they they can fully trust that their
guys have gotten the message from mike
tomlin and from the veteran leaders on
the team
to not screw around that's what makes it
so stunning that the patriots had
a covet issue because i thought they'd
be the least likely team to to fall into
that trap
the steelers i think in reality are the
least likely team to have to deal with
it
yeah ben roethlisberger if you remember
mike i think it was right before the
season started or maybe right when the
season
started talked about we're gonna do the
right things on this team
we're not gonna go out and eat we're not
gonna i think he's homeschooling his
kids if i remember the quote
uh accurately he's doing everything
right and said he expects all the other
players on the team to do that so that's
veteran leadership right there
telling the the other players this is
what we're going to do this is how we're
going to stay healthy and so far
whatever the steelers are doing it's
work for them
and they do like look like they are the
team right now the healthiest
without covet issues everything else
they're just rolling along
uh and and the train is is on the tracks
and and moving toward the playoffs and
potentially a super bowl
that said when i went back and watched
the raven steelers game last night and
again early this morning
my big takeaway was how in the hell did
the ravens lose that game there's a
rematch coming up
three weeks in two days thanksgiving
night heinz field and pittsburgh
that's a big game for the steelers to
assert that it really is a special
season
for them hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports